Hey welcome to my model lifestyle
channel I am Daniel Maritz. If you have
not subscribed yet please do, to you see
the upcoming videos. Now, you want to
know how to get a model agency? Well
let's get into this
all right so how do you get a modeling
agency? Well there are four steps that
you need to follow. Number one: take some
snapshots, do some measurements, and you
can also do an introduction video.
This is just so you show your
personality to the model agency. The
second step is you send this material
off to a model agency, the third step is
you go for an interview after you've got
a good response with them and the fourth
step is you just sign a contract and
then you are a model, but wait let me explain
this in more detail and give you my best
tips. Number one is you take good
snapshots, the measurements and
the optional video. So the snapshots, how
do you do that? Well there are two very
very important things that you need to
remember here: Number one, you need to
take good quality photos. Take it in
front of a clear background. White is
probably the best color and then you
stand out a little bit more. Fitted
clothing is the best and preferably
black, because then the model agency can
see your body a little bit more clearly.
Now how do you take the photos? Well
let's start with the head shot. The head shot, take one picture from the left side 45
degrees take the picture take two photos
looking to the camera,  the first picture
don't smile just look normal. The
second one give a little bit of a smile
so that the model agency can see your
teeth and then lastly for the headshot
45 degrees right. Okay, so after you've
got the headshot go to the upper body
and you do exactly the same. Take left 45
to the camera and right 45. After you are
done with the upper body go to the full
length shot. Do exactly the same, take left 45
camera, and right 45. Now the measurements:
You don't need to take all the
measurements of your whole body.
Just take your length, your chest size
waist size, and lastly your hip size. All
right so you got your snapshots, you got
your measurements, you can also do the
introduction video where you just show
the agency your personality. Let me show
you mine just as an example:
if you're finished with the first step
the second step all you need to do is
send those material off to a model agency.
Send your snapshots, your measurements
and also your video. But remember the
video is optional. Look on the internet
look at a few model agencies in your
area send the material off and just say
hey I'm Daniel, I'm from South Africa. I
really want to become a model, here are
my measurements and my snapshots. Please
let me know if you're interested. That's
it. You don't need to explain a lot more.
Once you've got the response from an
agency set up an interview and go and
see them, go and sit down with them
You need to really see if
you like the agency and if they like you
Now if you are happy with the agency go
ahead and sign the contract. That is the
fourth and last step. Then that's it, you
are a model congratulations!!!! But you're
not an International model yet. Now this
is just where you're starting. Now you
need to get a model portfolio, you need
to learn posing, there's a lot of stuff
you need to learn. I'm gonna make some
more videos so please subscribe so you
can check those out! But if you really
want to invest in your modeling career I
have added my eBook which you can find
here in the description. So thank you for
watching the video
see you in the next one
all right
and then you go alright so now all you
have to do